some experts say the most harmful time
to give a child a cellphone is in middle
school that kids are getting their first
devices at younger and younger ages new
data from Common Sense Media released
early to CBS News says 84 percent of
kids have smartphones by 13 or 14 years
old an experimental curriculum created
by a college professor aims to reach
younger kids Mike Oliver visited some
fifth and sixth graders learning about
privacy before it's too late
good morning good morning for most kids
receiving their first cell phone doesn't
come with a set of instructions on how
to protect their privacy this curriculum
now offered at a handful of schools in
the New York area was designed to do
just that teachers are hoping students
walk away with an important lesson over
using devices can lead to over sharing
and oversharing can lead to trouble what
is privacy
how does privacy affect my life
protecting their digital privacy may be
one of the most important lessons for
the future of these fifth graders what
can we do to protect their information
and there are two things good behavior
and responsible choices beyond the fun
of snapchat streaks and Minecraft
marathons these students are benefiting
from a curriculum rarely taught he just
told me that he got hacked at st.
Michael's School in Union New Jersey the
students are social media savvy and
already engrossed in a digital world how
many of you feel you can't live without
your phones and how old are you you're
ten you feel like you can't live without
your phone I think family life is
changing relationships were changing and
parents were getting worried Seton Hall
Law Professor Gaia Bernstein designed
the class for this pivotal moment in
modern life a study shows 50% of teens
feel they are addicted to their mobile
devices why are you targeting kids this
age some of those kids we just saw they
don't even have a phone yet it's much
harder to influence people who are
already made choices who are completely
embroiled in social networks we thought
there's this
when you get your first cell phone were
with the kids are more likely to listen
more likely to listen start talking and
hopefully begin to understand how their
actions online can impact their daily
lives that's really embarrassing right
and some of that information never goes
away so you should always keep in mind
the consequences of sharing the
information and this lime is a butter
sign eleven-year-old Ava's Ally
graduated from the class earlier this
year she got her first phone a few
months ago and already has three
Instagram accounts one solely for slime
I'm actually not on it as much as people
are cuz I always like going on phone and
I see like 20 text message I'm like
where did that come from
Ava's parents trust her to use judgment
when it comes to her phone but her mom
stresses one important lesson remember
every photo every text is indelible and
when you send that out in 10 seconds or
less it's in cyberspace for everyone to
read to see it can go all over the world
the digital privacy class at our school
hammered that point home it was
important thing I learned was probably
like to be aware that some of the stuff
you post affects other people
so now maybe you take a moment before
you post something and you think hmm
this is safe yeah
so I always make sure it my friends if
it's okay if I post something with them
they always ask me I learned that a lot
of the stuff I thought I was doing that
was safe was really not she's such a
great kid to graduate the students had
several homework assignments one was to
turn their phone off for an entire
weekend the other was to download the
moments app which tracks how much time
they spend on their devices the students
we spoke to were surprised at the hours
a day they actually spend online that
was a real eye-opener for them I think
it must be hard for parents of little
kids these days to decide when they
should get the phone because they are
getting it younger but I think you need
it for safety they say that but then
also the students were saying our
parents they didn't grow up with
smartphone know we do know we weren't
taught so they're hoping that these
lessons extended the pain what's great
about the lessons it teaches them to be
mindful and to interact with these
things with intention so that you're not
just being
enacted - without thinking and that's
the first picture I was ten I worried
about people stealing my lunch not my
password very fascinating Meg thank you